hi i'm kevin mcgary and i'm kayla
wallace you may recognize us from when
calls the heart head on tight
oh that fiona she's so full of surprises
but for now we are trading the frontier
for flutters with our new hallmark
channel flick feeling butterflies
premiering march 12th at 8 p.m you uh
got something up here it's a little bit
down here
to celebrate we are going to interview
each other for e.t come fly away with us
you hit me i hit
you what's one thing that you know now
that you didn't know before we started
the movie i know that people should
plant milkweed butterflies feed off
milkweed and there's a shortage of it
did you know that i do now and so is
everybody else is watching this
thank you
what kind of animal-themed movie would
you never say yes to
snakes i think it would be like love
with the ko brothers like under the
cobra sky or
you know something like that i would
have to pass yeah you can count me out
on that too snakes spiders absolutely
not
um spiderman
that's a different
story though not really okay love with
spiders okay i do spiders for spiderman
it's a hallmark spiderman
this is an important one how likely are
you to work with kevin mcgarry again
very likely
you don't have to you don't have to
pretend the camera's on you how likely
are you to work with kevin maguire again
100 i will work with kevin mcgarry again
you're such a good actress okay okay
do you remember the first time you ever
felt butterflies
it was with you
really yeah only time
only time
next question when was your first time
when i was seven
and i'm just finding this out now yeah
sorry
well
next question in this movie
emily teaches garrett the art of caring
for butterflies what is your favorite
thing
that i
kevin have taught you
you have taught me to live in the moment
you really have wow this is way deeper
than i'm sorry
that's just the truth like driving
that's just the truth yeah
that and being true to who you are this
these are these are deep things but
that's the truth so what have i taught
you
well i mean yours was such a sweet
answer i can't i was going to say like
cooking
and you taught me lots of stuff and i
don't think we have to get into
everything in front of this camera here
but one thing you are a very good cook
and you've taught me how to make
more than one dish so i don't starve to
death while you're not at home in
feeling butterflies emily gets the
opportunity of a lifetime that changes
her life and career
what was that moment for you a
career-changing moment i do anything
that is hard in it when calls the hearts
heartland open open hearts and open
hearts which was this kind of like
doctor
teen show
um it was the first kind of thing i got
hired on as like a regular and i learned
a lot and it was like almost like a
school for learning for me that was the
first time that i was like able to pay
bills and
not work in a restaurant
you know yeah what about you it was my
first day of filming on when calls the
heart back in season six
and i was still working at a restaurant
and because of wayne calls the heart i
couldn't work at the restaurant anymore
and i literally pulled into
the lot and i sent my resignation letter
and then walked to my trailer and i was
like this is pretty cool this is a movie
moment
i thought you were going to say because
you met me and you went with career as
well and that's important next question
okay
okay how does your character
on when calls the heart compare with
your character and feeling butterflies
and who do you relate to more oh
fiona
on one calls the heart and emily in
feeling butterflies are very similar
very similar that they're both career
go-getters they are boss ladies running
their own thing
and
[Music]
they differ in the fact that i think
emily's a little more shy a little more
reserved fiona isn't afraid to say
anything basically i relate to a bit of
the two of them i can be pretty which
one more i believe is a question i can
pull it up again
yes
what do you relate to more
emily i don't do well with confrontation
i think that's that's basically what it
comes down to i'm i'm a scared little
kitten when it comes time to
complain about you could be
you can you can hold your own come on i
can be ferocious well i'm just looking
over it the camera's on don't get the
wrong idea i'm a very nice person i
think but you can hold your own
are you more like nathan on when calls
the heart
like garrett
i don't have the money that garrett has
unfortunately i don't think i'm like
nathan though nathan is a bit more
stern he's a bit more regimented
yeah you're pretty jolly am i yeah i i
i'd sing neither i'm a chameleon
and you'll never know the real me you
will but you'll never know the real me
butterfly expert is quite a unique job
if you weren't an actor what job would
you have
i would be in
the food industry somehow i would be a
chef i would be
working with food i would be tasting
food
eating i'd just be eating is that a job
if you were not an actor what would you
be i don't know
fired by a lot of jobs i think because
i'm just not good at many other things i
think i would i like carpentry it would
have to be something creative you know
something to you know build or something
like that i think
i wouldn't have the patience to be a
mechanic
yeah maybe like carpentry or something
like that final question
what was your favorite thing
about working together
and does working with your significant
other
may make things easier or
more complicated
definitely easier
really yeah it made working together
working across from somebody who you
already have those feelings for us that
part came super easy yeah i guess it was
it's easier to do like a romance movie
with
your partner and my favorite part of
working with you was seeing
how you work like your work ethic and
your
the way you approach
scenes
it's different than i approach scenes
like you know the words
that's
you you know the the script
i know the script he knows this i just
maybe tend to go a bit loosey-goosey
with it but he's very uh in the moment
again
in real life and as an actor
i would say my favorite thing about
working with you
i think it's your work ethic here are
those people that like color code the
scripts and put in the little you know
different tags on it and for all the
scenes and everything and i think that's
just amazing and you're you were just a
pleasure to work with and it was just
you were always there we were able just
to kind of enjoy the whole thing
together so
i've never done that before and it was a
lot of fun you're really pretty
my dad thinks so the guy has a total
crush on you i kind of like him so
we've worked together on a tv show yeah
check we've worked together on a movie
yeah and now we've interviewed each
other which was your favorite
well i think this interview went pretty
well
and i think the movie's gonna do very
well
and i know our tv she does really well
so
i think they're all winners across the
board
i think so too so make sure you check
out feeling butterflies march 12th what
time 8 p.m 8 p.m on our channel
[Music]
you